(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
- [Kelly] Hello, It's nice to
see you. Have y'all ever met?
- No, we haven't met before.
- No, no.
I was thinking, I've gotta ask you
for some dance moves, man.
- Oh man, I've got you,
I've got you covered.
- Yeah, you can boogie.
- Yeah.
- I can tell, he can boogie.
- I was gonna ask you, do you
dance? Do you like dancing?
- I like dancing, but...
- Yeah.
- I can't say anything about
dancing sitting next to him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Listen, anybody can
dance, everybody can dance.
- That's right, that's right.
- That's a lie. (Kelly laughs)
- [Jay] You've just gotta feel it right?
I've gotta tell you one
thing though, before...
- [Kelly] What?
- Before we move on.
My mom, told me, she's like,
"When you go out there, just,
just tell her I voted for her".
I'm like, "Mom, that is old news.
I don't think she wants to hear that".
- It's not old news, it's
still why I'm sitting here.
- But she supported you.
- So, I'm appreciative, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And she really loves you and
she wanted me to tell you that.
And she's gonna be very happy
that I said that on the stage.
- Oh, that's so, that's so awesome.
(audience applauds) I'm not,
this isn't like, lip service.
I, people still come up to me in Target
and say that all the time and
I'm like, really thankful.
- [Jay] Yeah, yeah.
- Like, and it's a cool
way to have a career,
like, people wanted an album from me,
- They wanted you, yeah.
- They voted you in.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Like that's a
cool way to have a career.
- It is really cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah, so I'm thankful,
I love it. (Jay laughs)
We need, we need to talk
about the new season of "Magnum P.I."
So, what can you tell us about
what's happening right now?
- The new season is a lot of the same.
There's a lot of action, a lot of fun.
There's this, very strong
family sort of quality
to all the characters in the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jay] So, so I mean, it's kind of,
all the stuff that we expect,
but I also direct an episode.
- Oh, is that something
you're interested in doing?
- I directed one last...
- That's cool.
- I love it, I love it.
It's, it's this really,
kind of interesting thing
where as an actor, Jay Hernandez,
the individual has to
kind of stay in his lane.
- [Kelly] Hmm.
- But as a director, you can kind of,
go outside and play outside
the boundaries a little bit.
So, that's one thing that I love about it.
- [Kelly] It's interesting because I,
I've never had any interest of behind the,
like I've just never, I,
it's just never pulled at me.
And it's interesting, like,
I feel like it's actors
a lot of times too.
Like, y'all not, not just musicians,
it's like actors really
like to be a part of
the whole story, not just
their one characters.
I find that a lot on the couch.
- [Jay] Yeah, yeah.
I think, I think what it is,
is like, there's just a type of freedom
that you have as a director
that you don't necessarily
have as an actor,
because you know, you're
just not afforded the liberty
to play a million different
characters sometimes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, like whatever they think I am,
it's like I've gotta kind
of stay in that lane.
- [Kelly] I hate that when
people get type casted.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What's the craziest stunt though?
because it's, it's action
packed, so like what...
- [Jay] There's a,
there's a lot of action.
- Do you like the action, doing all that?
- I love it, I love it.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I, I absolutely love it.
I don't love it when I have,
like a two pound burrito
and then got to sprint
on top of a rooftop or
something like that.
(Kelly chuckles)
- Yeah.
- Don't love that, but I've
done everything on the show.
Car stunts, like guns,
like chasing people,
fight scenes, all that stuff.
But one of the coolest things was,
in the episode I directed last season.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was, we were doing
this underwater stuff
and it was just like this easy shot
of me kind of like,
floating through the ocean
looking for some sunken vessel and...
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- And, and, well that's not
the coolest part about it.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So I'm, I'm like, probably
60 feet under the surface
of the ocean and the
coordinator, stunt guy,
he tells me to turn around and I,
I turn around and there was a pod of like,
60 dolphins that were...
- Amazing.
- Swimming by.
And you see like the little,
like the little baby ones.
- [Derek] The baby ones are best.
- [Jay] They were playing
around with the, with the...
- Yeah.
- With the older ones.
- [Kelly] That's magical.
- It was like, surreal,
magical, it was crazy.
And it was, it felt
like I really understood
that they were a family.
It was the strangest experience,
but it was just beautiful.
- I mean, you, we don't pause enough.
Like, that's a moment that like,
not really anyone's gonna have.
- Yeah, no, and and...
- Do you know what I'm
saying? How special was that?
- It was work for me, you know?
Like I was, I was
getting paid to be there.
- Yeah.
- Like, I would pay for
that experience, but.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's...
- But nobody gets that kind of experience
just out in the wild.
That's like really cool.
- [Jay] Yeah, it was beautiful.
- I can't imagine the energy off of that.
What's like the wildest or most like,
dangerous thing you've done on stage or?
- Well...
- Or in life?
- Well, I, I'm, I'm kind of similar.
I, I love skydiving, I love crazy stuff.
And swimming with dolphins
or humpback whales
in Tonga has been incredible.
But, there was this one experience...
- [Kelly] Wow!
- [Derek] You, you know Bear Grylls?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, I went on an adventure with him
and we were in Bulgaria
and we went skydive,
after we were in this,
swimming in a glacier lake.
We get in this helicopter, we go up,
and he's like,
"Derek, All right, this
is what we're gonna do,
we're gonna just jump outta
this helicopter, da da da".
And there's this guy with
this like, black mask on
and I get in there,
strap in, and we're like,
"Oh, we've gotta jump out now, now, now".
And I'm realizing that I don't
have these straps here in.
- Oh, no.
- And then, I'm hanging out
the window and I'm like,
"I'm not strapped in!
I'm not strapped in!"
And he's like, "One, two..."
- Oh, my god.
- "Okay, now let's do it for real.
Let's get you strapped in".
(audience laughs)
And I was like, I, I, I
thought it was the end of me.
(Kelly gasps)
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Like, I...
- I thought, I thought,
I was like, "This is it.
I'm gonna die, here we go".
- I was not breathing in that story
and I didn't realize it until the release.
- [Derek] Yeah.
(Derek chuckles)
- Like, wow, what a way
to mess with someone.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He did that on purpose
making, like obviously, like.
- I feel like he's done
that more than once.
Like, he likes screwing with people.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- I, there might have
been a little bit of,
something coming out, you know.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah, right.
The glacier water changed color.